in the last node,
we mentioned that meaningful
apps come from great intention.
Now the best way to
surface this intention
is to build a user interface that's
easy to use and has clear value.
For the quake report app,
we want to allow users to get a sense of
earthquake activity around the world.
In order to do that, we've identified
certain pieces of metadata that
will be most helpful in
understanding that activity.
We even came up with a few Macleod
ideas for how to display that data.
And to kick them up to another level,
we roped in one of our UX designers
to develop a more refined design.
Let's take a look at the final mock up.
Okay, so here's the design
mock of the main list view.
Simple and clean, right?
Pretty cool.
Now, if we zero in here on the list item
design, you'll notice on the left that
we have a colored circle that
contains the magnitude of quake.
Now also notice the fluctuation in color
that we have here in these different
circles to reflect the change
in magnitude strength.
Now, this is the most important
piece of information about a quake.
So the circle and the color provide
a good way to draw prominence to this
piece of important data.
Now in the center, we have the general
location name with the details
highlighted above it using a slightly
bolder font, all caps and lighter text.
Now all these subtle choices combine to
help focus the user on what's important.
And then lastly,
on the right side we have the date and
the time formatted nicely.
Also using a similar stacked layout
as location name in the details.
Some of you may be thinking what do I do
if I don't have access to a designer?
Now while it's certainly advantageous
to have a formal design perspective,
it's also very possible to channel
some solid design on your own.
It may just mean you'll have to
spend some more time iterating on
a design idea.
And ground your ideas around some
guidelines such as the material design
guidelines here.
See the instructor notes for some
additional tips on building a great UI.